imple dan you know we have a little more
bonus coverage for you last hour we had
the great Bears quarterback legendary
Bears quarterback mr. whiskey yes who
called on for the called in for the
specific purpose to check on you not to
pitch a product in this way
it's just ancillary okay and you said I
need some more NFL quarterbacks at least
there's one guy you'd think would
calling to give you some love okay he's
on the phone hello Dan
Ross I'm doing better yeah I'm doing a
whole lot better better yes I am I
well wait there's your wife there could
I talk to her make sure that she knows
I'm cured I'm feeling better when Sierra
calls then but uh I I did say earlier in
the show you know I haven't heard from
Tom Brady yet haven't heard from Russell
Wilson and then I said well I didn't
care if Russ called but if Sierra called
in then I would care but this is just as
good trust me this is the next best
thing than your wife I'm gonna be the
next best thing but I'm a I'm a far
distant second yes yes you are but you
know your place but no thank you I'm
feeling a lot better but went through
some some bad times for about six years
and but everything's good now I'm
feeling a whole lot better a whole lot
better you know I felt like NC State
that's how that's how bad I've been
feeling it was like when you were
playing at NC State well I think I think
you know your your vulnerability your
honesty to all your fans I mean you has
so many fans that listen to you I we
didn't know I listened CD we listened to
you at the house you know I think
mornings when we get to and just you've
always been a guy of great great
character guy who's always influenced so
many people guy who's it's been very
very very inspirational you know and
also you've been a guy who's given me a
chance you know so I'm always grateful
for the opportunity you've given me ever
since my rookie year really to be on
your show it's been such an honor and
just the difference that you've been
making my life and I always have fun in
your show I always feel the most natural
on your show just because they bring the
best out of people
Thank You Russ I really appreciate who
you are and what you mean so you know
but you know you always go against the
grain my brother but now that you're
rich could you buy me something I would
feel a little bit better if you bought
me something mean your words are nice I
don't don't take this the wrong way but
it'd be nice if you bought me something
small like a small boat that I could
take the dance out would be nice Paulie
what size do we need I get 21-footer
hear us not bad huh yeah you know what
I'll name the boat 12th man how about
that yeah you're 12
yeah yeah dumb 12 I want to I want to
check with my CFO see if see if she'll
clear it not he'll clear it hey thank
you for calling in and thanks for being
a friend for for a long time we
appreciate it
okay chase you man preciate your heart
that's so Russell Wilson jr. the third
once again emotional moment Fritzi
somehow found a bad phone connection
somehow some things never change a
beautiful moment could get turned around
I just want to say how much you really
mean for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
streamed for free on VR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app